today on the matt wall show an
award-winning student of the sciences
tries to debate ben shapiro about gender
ideology and the resulting footage shows
us everything wrong with academia the
sciences and gender ideology also a
black supremacist commits a terrorist
attack on new york there is a definite
trend here that
the media of course doesn't want to talk
about but we will plus a teacher puts on
a drag show for students and popular
youtubers face vicious backlash for
comparing abortion to the holocaust
they're right of course but they weren't
right when they apologize we'll talk
about all that and more today on the
matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know if you've been listening to my
show for a while you're probably
familiar with one of our top sponsors
rock otto recently my producer mckenna
told me about her own experience
shopping with rock auto and how great it
was for her
as a person who knows nothing about cars
it's a riveting story let me tell you
about it mckenna was carpooling with her
boyfriend during an ice storm and turn
on his windshield wipers before he got
in the car to help get rid of the ice
but with this simple act she destroyed
his windshield wipers and they had to
drive in the rain with wipers that
barely could wipe the rain away during
the drive to work she figured it was
worth checking rockauto.com to see if
they had replacement options for the
windshield wipers and sure enough
she was able to buy some new windshield
wipers for the car that are made to deal
with ice and for a surprisingly
reasonable price so if you're like
mckenna and need a quick fix or if you
need to do some major repairs you should
check out rockauto.com once you go to
rockauto.com a list will guide you
through every single make and model and
you could you could possibly imagine and
you'll find everything that you need at
rockauto.com it gives you a list of
every part available for your vehicle
included with the part descriptions are
photos and specs so you can feel
confident that you're choosing the
correct parts so go to rockauto.com for
your auto part needs today and write
walsh in their how did you hear about us
box so they know that i'm the one that
sent you that's rockauto.com to shop for
your auto part needs today
so i noticed last night that ben shapiro
was trending on social media and as i
clicked on his name to find out what he
had done this time i immediately learned
from many left-wing accounts that he had
been apparently
totally owned and demolished and
destroyed
in a debate with a college student
during the q a portion of his speech at
unc greensboro this week now i confess
that i was uh i was
a little biased maybe but i was
skeptical of this claim for many obvious
reasons then i went and watched the
trending video in question and i
discovered that my skepticism was
certainly justified to put it mildly
more than that in fact the exchange
encapsulates nearly everything that's
wrong with the left's approach to debate
in general and debate about gender
ideology in particular
these flaws are only further underscored
by the fact that the left is hailing and
applauding the college student in spite
of the fact that he by any objective
measure and speaking now scientifically
made an absolute ass of himself but
don't take my word for it let's uh let's
go to the tape and watch some of this
i'm a mathematician and a physicist here
a double major and i also just won the
most prestigious award in the country to
pursue research at any institution i
want the national science foundation
graduate research fellowship so i think
i'm pretty you know qualified to say
that most of what you're saying is based
on like old data um but my question to
you and so
last month but sure um like for example
gender identity disorder that's the
dsm-4 bro we use the dsm-5 now for
psychologists to be able to talk i
literally cited the dsm five in the
speech and it's called gender dysphoria
which is literally that i use throughout
the speech not generally you sound like
a boso
and you can't even make your wife bro so
what's good
now a couple of things here before we uh
watch the rest of the club first of all
the kid makes a number of false and
confused claims right off the bat but
rather than let ben correct the record
he interrupts calls ben a bozo
because those are the insults that kids
are using these days apparently and
makes an obscene comment about uh ben's
wife now
we saw how will smith reacted to a
comment about his own wife and we saw
that smith was largely defended by the
left for reacting that way but chris
rock didn't deserve to be smacked in the
face for making such an incredibly mild
joke
this cut on the other hand
actually does deserve the chris rock
treatment i mean you don't talk about a
man's wife that way i understand why ben
didn't climb down from the stage and up
into the stands and try to commit
assault during the yaf event of course
but my point is simply that
this is a kid who needs to learn to
watch his mouth i mean something has
gone seriously wrong in society when a
young man feels comfortable
speaking that way
to another man about that man's wife
and one of these days he's going to run
his mouth to someone who is not standing
on stage with cameras all around and
he'll learn his manners the hard way
also before devolving in almost
immediately into ad hominems
he begins by listing his credentials the
credentials are of course completely
irrelevant to the conversation and will
not make his wrongness magically right
and that's not to say that he's lying
about the credentials though the most
concerning and disturbing thing is that
he is not apparently the north state
journal a newspaper north carolina they
looked into this and here's what they
found quote one uncg student who
got to ask a question boasted about
being a mathematician and physicist and
recently winning a prestigious national
science foundation graduate research
fellowship award the fellowship which is
nsf says is the oldest graduate
fellowship of its kind spans five years
including three years of an annual
stipend of thirty four thousand dollars
and a cost of education allowance of
twelve thousand dollars paid to the
institution a search of the awardee list
located four
students but only one individual quentin
hosea merit matched the questioner's
description and received an award in
physics and astronomy quantum
information science for 2022. north
state journal reached out to uncg for
comment but did not receive a response
by publication time additionally the
twitter account for the physics
department limited who can see their
tweets after our reporter questioned
them about merit
so apparently the kid with a bad haircut
who thinks yora bozo is an argument and
who accuses a father of three of being a
virgin and who thinks women have penises
and who couldn't even be bothered to
wear a shirt to the event has indeed
received a prestigious academic award
now rather than this fact causing us to
see the stupid kid in a better light it
should cause us to see academia in an
even worse light than we did before
which frankly in my case i didn't think
was possible
now let's return to the clip and see
what else sideshow bob has to say
so
number let me just say
the nice thing about having several
small questions
we're using a western colonial idea of
gender then why should it apply if we're
using because the gender binary is a
western colonial as a western
colonialist framework of gender you're
right men and women don't exist in any
other country no no no no no no no no no
think about native americans
third gender people i'm not saying that
third gender people like the native
american societies western african
societies like southern native american
societies like mexico so in other places
that are not white dominated and they
like the united states or europe and so
you're saying
so non-white people i'm a mathematician
and a physicist you cannot tell me so i
have a question and also you're not a
biologist so i have a question i'm a
mathematician and a physicist what in
the hell do you know about human biology
and you got your law degree from harvard
what do you know about biology
and frankly
and frankly i would ask another question
if your logic is so flawed as a
mathematician and a physicist i would
suggest that whichever institution gave
you an award revoke it immediately
i'm a mathematician and a physicist he
screams while making one erroneous an
incoherent claim after another he says
that the gender binary is a western
colonial idea now even if this were an
accurate claim if it were somehow true
that western colonialists were the first
ones to realize that men and women exist
that wouldn't in and of itself disprove
the gender binary on the contrary in
fact it would just be one more great and
true thing that western colonialists
introduced to the world it'd be another
w for western colonialism i guess
but sadly uh western colonialism cannot
claim credit for that the so-called
gender binary is as old as humanity
itself it is decidedly not true at all
even a little
that non-western countries have an idea
of human sex that falls outside of the
binary in fact
every non-western society on earth
and in the history of the earth
believes that there are only males and
females and i defy you to provide an
actual example of an exception to that
rule
now they may in some cases have some
version of cross-dressing or you know
what we would call gender bending or
whatever but
um they don't believe that men can
actually be women the claim made by this
leftist and by almost every leftist
is the idea that um is that you know the
idea that that men have penises as
uniquely western now if that were true
you should be able to travel outside of
the western world and find hundreds of
cultures that believe
women can have penises
but you don't find that in fact you
don't find any cultures outside the
western world that believe that
i should know
i actually went to africa and
investigated this question
you'll see what i discovered in my
documentary what is a woman when it's
released in may go to what is woman.com
and see the teaser for that for now
suffice it to say that this kid is uh
full of something and it ain't knowledge
i can tell you that
he mentions native american cultures
this is a reference to the two spirits
quote unquote which is allegedly the
native american version of
transgenderism they put it into the lgbt
alphabet thing now and they put it in
there um so it's lgbt qia
ii
s whatever
the problem is that the term two-spirit
was invented in 1990
by lgbt activists that's how far back
ancient native american history of 1990
is when they came up with this
it is itself a modern western concept
and that's the theme here if you'll
notice
it's an important thing to point out
actually
it is gender ideology
not the gender binary that is modern and
western
gender ideology was invented in the west
by westerners very recently
western liberals have
taken this idea
and tried to spread it throughout the
world
that is the sort of colonization that
happens these days
gender ideology turns out
is not only modern and western but also
in its own way colonialist
the worst kind of colonialism
this is the ideological colonialism
as the left as as you know
liberals in the west
try to ideologically colonize the globe
they may not be planting the flag of of
a nation
although that happens as well but no
instead they plant the gay pride flag
and that's the kind of colonization that
happens
so this kid was um
on exactly the opposite side of the
truth
upside down backwards incoherent
angry stupid confused
and yet
an award-winning academic
it is terrifying to consider how often
all of those things
tend to go to go together
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well i uh i did mention ever so
seamlessly the uh my documentary which
is coming up what is a woman again you
go to what is woman.com and see the
teaser for there for that
and uh that's one of the things i i you
know i was just thinking about watching
that clip of this um kid is just okay
wait like
well we'll see okay you you can make
these claims about other cultures in the
world have you actually gone there and
asked them
i did
and you'll see how they respond
you'll see i don't think you're gonna
like it very much uh but that is you
know as you know that documentary in the
book that's coming out as well which you
can pre-order on amazon is what makes me
i mean this that kid was a was an
award-winning physicist he claims
um but i am an award-winning women's
studies scholar and before that as you
know i was in award-winning um awards
that i basically give myself lgbt author
with my book johnny the walrus and if
you have not um pre-ordered johnny the
walrus yet and these these books will
actually be shipping very very soon i
promise you can still go to amazon
and uh order john the walrus or go to
johnnywalrus.com and get my
award-winning lgbt children's book so
you should do that right now okay
we'll start with this from the daily
mail a multi-state manhunt is currently
underway for the person of interest
suspected of unleashing hell on a
brooklyn subway train during tuesday's
morning commute as a gunman fired more
than 20 rounds leaving 10 riders wounded
and 13 others injured in the ensuing
chaos before his automatic weapon jammed
the nypd released photos of frank james
62 who rented an abandoned u-haul that's
linked to the shooting scene and who has
made concerning quote-unquote threats
against new york city mayor eric adams
and railed against the city's
homelessness crisis
um
commuters on the n train tuesday morning
describe how a man wearing a
construction vest threw a smoke grenade
into their subway car when it was in
between stations and then opened fire
terrified passengers tried to get onto
the next carriage where the doors locked
when the train pulled into the 36th
street station in sunset park the gunman
fled
um
and
managed to escape in the middle of new
york city and is still right now at
large now
there is more about the suspect that is
relevant that we should talk about
but before we get there um
kathy hokul the governor you know she
was on the scene very quickly
and instead the first thing she wanted
to talk about of course is well you we
we can already know we already know
where she's going to go with this but
let's watch the clip anyway
this is an active shooter situation
right now in the city of new york i just
get off the phone with the mayor he's
recovering well he's monitoring he's
actively engaged in this situation i
honor to let him know that the people of
the entire state of new york
stand with the people of the city this
community and we say no more
no more mass shootings
no more disrupting lives don't worry
creating heartbreak for people just
trying to live their lives as normal new
yorkers
it has to end it ends now
and we are sick and tired of reading
headlines about crime whether they're
mass shootings or the loss of a teenage
girl
or a 13 year old
it has to stop
i'm committing the full resources of our
state
to fight this surge of crime
this insanity that is seizing our city
because we want to get back to normal
it has been a long hard two years
that's what we crave
that sense of stability and normalcy and
this is what the mayor and i are going
to continue to work toward and i thank
the partners
the brave
people of the mta the first ones who had
the sense the drivers of the train to
leave the station to make sure no more
victims could be hurt
the nypd
fdny
state
police everyone involved in this has one
purpose
and has to stop the insanity of these
crimes
you'll hear now
from our fire department i want to thank
them for being there to help us defuse a
volatile situation
but we'll be giving continued reports as
this day unfolds
again we ask everyone to be careful be
cautious report what you see
these these people are so incompetent
and of course kathy hokule is not going
to be able to rise to a moment like this
because she's just a perpetually failed
politician who's managed to fail her way
up and uh ended up with the governorship
without being elected to it so she's
totally unprepared for this and she's
rambling basically incoherently what is
it we're we're tired of the insanity of
these crimes in the last two years the
last two years what did you roping covet
into it what does that have to do with
anything and then uh should no more mass
shootings of course that is her
gesturing towards
in a not so subtle way gun control and
uh she's allowing the media and
everybody else on the left to make that
connection more explicit which of course
they did right away is this is why we
need gun control um
even though they already have strict gun
laws in new york and that obviously did
not prevent this from happening you know
the other thing too is is um
this scumbag
is still on the loose right now
okay he's still out there he's at large
at right right now and certainly at the
time when that speech was given
so we don't want to hear right now about
your plans to stop mass shootings in
general
what about this specific situation what
do you have for that
because we know that what they always
want to do is they want to make it about
gun control they want to use they want
to use every crisis to their political
benefit of course
but the other thing that happens in the
midst of that is that we take these
specific situations
which had specific causes
and which need to be addressed in
specific ways and then you you you
broaden it and you turn it into this
kind of abstract thing of what are we
going to do about mass shootings and
just like violence in general
now before we hear instead of
immediately going to that
why don't you tell us how you're going
to catch this actual guy who's on the
loose
because that should be your first
uh priority
and
actually the first priority before
catching him would have been to stop him
from doing it in the first place
which it seems like
you should have been able to do
because um as is so often the case
with these um mass
mass killers or in this case attempt
attempted killers
he was known to law enforcement
so journalist andy noe has some more
information about frank james and just
reading from his twitter thread where
he's compiling a lot of this stuff
and uh you know and bringing things to
light that the media does of course is
not is not going to tell us about would
prefer if we didn't know
but this is what andy knows has he says
um nypd named frank james as a person of
interest in the brooklyn mass shooting i
looked into social media like the
waukesha suspect and the louisville blm
activist who allegedly tried to
assassinate a mayoral candidate he
appeared to be a fan of black
nationalism
uh and then he's got a whole bunch of
posts from this guy i mean frank james
was all over social media he was all
over youtube being very explicit about
the fact that he's you know about his
his racist uh feelings about white
people and also his violent tendencies
and the fact that he wanted to kill
people
um
says frank james the brooklyn mass
shooting person of interest made
disturbing posts recently suggesting he
was going to kill people
um uh some more social media posts by by
frank james
and just there's a whole bunch of posts
of him talking about how he wants to
kill people he hates white people
there's also as i said he had a youtube
channel where he was um
pretty open about the fact that he
despised white people here's just one
one example of one of the uh
one of this guy's uh youtube videos
where he's complaining about the fact
that kantanji jackson married a white
man let's watch this
i had no idea with that african name
that she would be married to
a white man one of my subscribers
brought that to my attention
yeah
our black sister supreme court justice
power to the people it's very 12
white man
i don't believe this [ __ ] oh god
wait a minute
this this is the [ __ ] right
there yet
there he is with
white man
black sister
can tantra tape
married to a white man
okay so there's that there's there's
also a video that uh andy noah posted we
don't need to play but he's he's walking
down the street in new york city and
just shouting at white people
and also asian people as well
um just kind of shouting at them and
calling them all evil and and racial
slurs and all the rest of it so
now um uh
so we know that this is a very clear
from his social media posts
this is a black supremacist hated white
people didn't just hate white people
hated asian people too
hated um everyone who's not black also
hated other black people as well it
would seem and that's
that's the thing that the media right
now is homing in on so this is we we
just played that for you you've seen
some of the social media posts
here's cnn okay
now this is like at the level of of
self-parody
but cnn had an article where they say
that the killer or the suspected killer
was had videos which were racist and
misogynistic
but here's what they say about that
um
many of the videos that james uploaded
included references to violence
including a had a set group of people he
believed had maligned him in addition to
broad societal and racial groups that he
appeared to hate
the speech was a common theme throughout
james's videos in which he repeatedly
espoused hatred toward african-americans
that's the only specific racial hatred
that cnn acknowledges is that he hated
black people
he was a black guy
the fact that almost all of his posts
were very directly targeted at i hate
white people
and i wish they were dead
doesn't get a mention from cnn
so this guy was known to the fbi
was threatening to kill people
made many racist videos and posts with
with oftentimes violent themes
and yet was not apprehended by law
enforcement ahead of time
and wasn't even kicked off of social
media
i mean i can't say that a male swimmer
is a man without getting kicked off
this guy could post videos of himself
walking down the street and screaming
about how he hates white people
not kicked off of social media
but you do notice a trend here we got
the the waukesha mass killing
was a black supremacist
this guy's a black supremacist
um
the uh
the attempted uh assassin of a mayoral
mayoral candidate in louisville black
supremacist capital police officer
killed last year black supremacist
now does this matter i mean is it worth
talking about it is
because first of all it's true it's just
it's a fact
about these crimes
and and
it's a fact people deserve to know
um it's also of course
if this had gone the other way and this
was a white guy ranting about non-white
people then we know the media would have
all the stuff all over the place but
then also it's important because
this is not like a random
pattern it's it's not a coincidence
i don't see how it's a coincidence that
we live in a culture right now
where it is acceptable
to hate white people and kids are having
this have even at very young ages are
having this ingrained into their minds
that white people are evil and
responsible for all the evils in the
world
there is this constant fomenting of
hatred towards white people and not just
hatred but also paranoia
about about about white people
and then what do you see you see these
mass
violent crimes
targeting white people
might we draw a connection is it
possible that that
these things are being encouraged
and that people who are already mentally
unbalanced they're healing hearing all
of this stuff
about how white people are evil
and they're being given a welcoming
environment to express and kind of dive
deeper into their own hatreds
might we draw that connection i think we
can
well we can
but um uh for from on a mainstream level
it the connection isn't going to happen
because this story is going to fall out
of the headlines
it's already on its way out of the
headlines a day later
and i can guarantee you by by the end of
the week by the end of the week
unless there's some new update they
catch the guy or something but barring
that by the end of the week this is not
even all it's not even on the home page
of cnn
and and that's i'm being optimistic by
saying it'll take to the end of the week
probably by later today if not tomorrow
it's gone
i mean look at the waukesha kill a
terrorist attack
many people were killed in that attack
thank god so far no one's died here
and they were able to erase that in 24
hours
a child was killed run over by a car
during a parade
24 hours later so it never
happened that's what they're going to do
here because they don't they have no
interest in talking about
um
the mainstreaming of anti-white hatred
and how that might be contributing to
these kinds of violent events they don't
want to talk about that
and also people in the media they don't
really care if
white people are
the victims of violence it's just it's
not they're not concerned about that
all right this is from the daily wire
last week um high schoolers in a
wisconsin town not far from madison had
to endure a sing a song and dance
routine by a french teacher
from their school who was dressed in
drag
uh shannon valladolid the
district's director of information
public relations reportedly admitted
that staff performances are vetted by
the high school's teaching faculty
french teacher matthew cashton whose
linkedin page states he is looking to
shift away from k-12 public education
into higher education to study abroad in
programming and advising performed for
the students during middleton high
school's fine arts week
empower wisconsin reported quote cashton
strutted on to the auditorium stage in a
high-cut
blue sequined dress red boots and a
blonde wig lip syncing and dancing to
rain on me by pop divas lady gaga and
ariana grande
it was all a surprise to the assembled
students who apparently had no idea
they're about to get a drag show from
one of their teachers
and we have footage of that let's play
just a little bit of that footage
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so
it's just a male teacher
in drag strutting around in front of his
uh minor students
no problem there at all
and this is how i mean just
think about how
like the
aside from the the perversion the
degeneracy involved here just the
the gold the the gall and the bulk can
we turn this off just turn it off i
can't look at it anymore
the gall and the gumption
to do this
to do it at all but especially to do it
right now
when everybody's talking about grooming
in the public schools
and for once there's actually kind of
some national focus on that issue
and the left is busy saying oh it's not
happening at all and then you decide to
do a drag performance
that you it's apparently vetted by the
administration
they saw this plan and said oh yeah
sounds good let's do that
obviously knowing that this video is
going to end up online it's not it's not
going to be a secret nothing is
especially not that
but they don't speaking of not caring
they just don't care
from the school system their attitude is
hey these are these are our kids not
yours you can complain about it all you
want
what are you going to do pull your kids
out and homeschool them
we know most of you probably won't so
complain all you want
that's their attitude a middleton cross
plains area schools parent alerted radio
host vicki mckenna in an email about
this writing
quote i send my children to school and
entrust them to
teachers that i have to believe are
professionals who won't destroy their
innocence for their own pleasure if
matthew cashton makes the decision to
perform his drag show at school what
else does he do in the classroom with a
room full of children what kind of
educators thought this was appropriate
drag shows are fine arts if a teacher is
a pole dance or stripper can they also
perform for my children i don't care
what matthew cashion does us out of
school i do care what he does at
middleton high school
and that is a very good question as well
if he's doing this on camera on stage
what does he do like if he's willing to
do that on stage
with everybody watching and when he must
know that there's probably with people
with their phones up what is he doing in
the classroom when when he's not on
stage
and when he's pretty confident that he's
not being filmed
this is uh yeah
grooming in the public school system
definitely
sexual abuse in the public school system
because i hope that um the conversation
as we're talking about grooming and
gender ideology and indoctrination of
students a very important issue
but i hope that and i think we're
starting to see this now that the
conversation also starts to include
a very related issue which is the sex
abuse epidemic in schools because the
fact is
that our schools as i have been
screaming for years and up until
recently like nobody seemed to care our
schools are crawling
with sex predators
uh with with perverts
and there's a reason why these people
want so desperately to talk to kids
about
about sex
i mean there's no reason why you would
want to put on women's clothes and strut
around on stage
in front of
uh in front of kids
other than you're you're a predator
and this has been a problem in the
school system for years and decades
there was as i've mentioned as you maybe
you've heard me mention before there was
a study commissioned by the department
of education
back in
2004 i believe which back then found
that one in 10 public school students
were targets of sexual misconduct by
teachers
now that works out to about five million
victims
at any given time
and this was a department of education
this isn't uh some right-wing propaganda
outlet this is the the department of
education did their own study and said
yeah this is a problem
back in 2004 they were at least willing
to be honest about it
it's probably not the case now
um so that's five million victims there
about four to five million victims and
out of that number three million
experienced actual sexual assault you
know sexual misconduct that includes
sexual harassment inappropriate
conversations between teachers and
students which is bad enough
but it also includes actual physical
sexual assault by teachers and if you
look at those numbers from the
department of education that's about 3
million victims
which means the epidemic in our schools
is at least 100 times worse than the
scandal in the catholic church
although it's gotten 100 times less
attention
and those numbers are for from over 15
years ago do we think that it's gotten
better magically
since then
i mean when when you have a sexual abuse
crisis in an institution and you don't
do anything about it
and you ignore it
and instead you start taking abusers and
you move them around to different
schools and everything
does the problem tend to get better on
its own
no it doesn't it's like if you if you
have a you know if you find a lump
somewhere on your body and you just
decide to ignore and hope it goes away
it's not going to that's not how a
cancer works it's just going to progress
unless you address the problem
aggressively
and it's the same thing with the cancer
in the public school system and that
that's only that's only uh talking about
abuse by teachers
abuse by students
of other students as a whole is its own
its own crisis we know what happened at
loudoun county
the ap again back when um some of these
institutions were willing to be a little
bit honest about this the ap did a a
report on this a few years ago and at
that time they found it said there was
17 000 cases
just at that time
of student on student abuse in a in a
four-year period leading up to that
report
and a lot of those stories are as we've
seen in loudoun county are downright
horrific
and we know the schools have done a
manifestly terrible job of handling
these cases sometimes they even cover
them up
what else can you expect there are there
are hundreds of deviants and perverts
working in the system this is a real
problem
an actual epidemic
and that's why every every day you can
go online you see another story of sex
abuse in the public school system uh the
post-millennial for example just from a
couple of days ago they've compiled uh
four more cases recent cases of teachers
charged with sexual abuse of minors
there was a case in california 56 year
old math teacher
faces allegations of sexual assault from
at least two students
in florida 30 year old thomas dean
former teacher at a private school
faces lewd
and molestation of a minor and that was
back in february there's an english
teacher in iowa
faces multiple rounds of charges of
sexual exploitation by a school employee
and north carolina 27 year old sean
hicks with science teacher at harnett
central middle school
faces three charges of indecent
liberties with a student and is jailed
on 50 000 bond
and there was also the most recent one
in oregon middle school teacher arrested
charged with sexual abuse and incest
in san jose jury issues 102 million
dollar award blame school district for
not stopping teacher sex abuse
this is an in an epidemic and it's and
you know there's 50 million kids
in the school system
who are
in in the potential pool of victims
maybe at some point we might start
talking about it
all right this is from cnn it says
oklahoma republican governor kevin
stitt on tuesday signed a bill into law
that makes performing an abortion
illegal in the state with an exception
only in the case of a medical emergency
the governor said in a statement as a
governor i represent all four four
million oklahomans and they
overwhelmingly support protecting life
in the state of oklahoma we want
oklahoma to be the most pro-life state
in the country we want to outlaw
abortion in the state of oklahoma senate
bill 612 which uh cleared the state
senate last year makes performing an
abortion
or attempting to perform one a felony
punishable by a maximum fine of 100 000
or a maximum of 10 years in state prison
or both
the law does not provide exceptions in
cases of rape and incest
under the measure the woman would not be
criminally charged or convicted for the
death of her unborn child the
legislation does not prohibit the use
sale prescription or administration of
contraceptives
and of course and even some people who
who call themselves claim to be
pro-lifers are
critical of the fact that there are no
exceptions for um rape and incest and
and uh and those kinds of extreme
you know very rare cases
well but you can't put an exception
if you're going to outlaw abortion there
can't be an exception
one reason is just from a practical
standpoint how do you and how do you
enforce that
if you say oh abortion is um
illegal
unless you tell us that you were raped
well there's
then there's there's
what's the enforcement enforcement
mechanism there but more importantly
the only reason to make abortion illegal
is that
the child in the womb is a human being
and has human rights
and it is not okay to intentionally
directly kill an innocent human being
that's the only reason to make abortion
illegal it's the best reason it's the
only reason it's the only reason you
need
and if that's the case that the um
the person in the womb is a person and
has human rights and ought to have legal
rights as well codifying those human
rights which they naturally have by the
nature of the fact that they are human
beings uh if that's the case then
it doesn't make any sense to say that oh
yeah well they have human rights unless
they were conceived in a certain way in
which case the rights don't don't hold
anymore
now you want to punish somebody for rape
punish the rapist not the baby
but we're starting to see this more and
more from from
some in the republican party going going
on offense more we know what's happening
in florida and some other states as well
whether whether it's the gender issue or
abortion
don't just sit around and say that well
there's we gotta wait for the supreme
court to speak before we can do anything
no if you're pro-life then you believe
that actual human beings children are
being
systematically slaughtered in this
country which means you have to do
everything in your power to stop it
and let the other side challenge you let
them take you to court do whatever
they're going to do
you're under no obligation to respect
roe v wade
roe v wade holds no
moral weight whatsoever it's not
legitimate
it's not morally legitimate which means
that if you're the governor of the state
if you're a state legislator you can
ignore it and just do what you're going
to do let them take you to court over
it which is what they're doing in
oklahoma
uh which is exactly what they should do
all right one other thing this is just
some some good news
more good news actually from cnbc fewer
than 10 000 people are using cnn plus on
a daily basis two weeks into its
existence according to people familiar
with the matter people spoke with that
cnbc of the condition of anonymity cnn
plus that's their streaming service
launched on march 29th the subscription
news streaming service which charges
5.99 a month or about 60 bucks annually
only became available on roku on monday
still is available android android tv
and right now there's it's a big crisis
at cnn because they've got
they've got 10 000 people using
their streaming service
which i mean
at least that's more people than
um
watch their normal network programming
especially when you take airports out of
the equation so you could look at it
from a positive angle like that i guess
but also not a surprise
you know you actually have to give
people a reason to subscribe you have to
give them content that they want to see
which i think cnn they they tended to
neglect that part of this equation let's
get now to the comment section
[Music]
nick c says i love how matt's segways
between topics are usually just him
staring silently at the camera for a
couple of seconds
alex says from the previous show i was
almost diagnosed with adhd but my
parents came in and said no you're not
gonna go on drugs because you don't fix
a five-year-old kid's unwillingness to
sit down in a classroom for eight hours
a day with pills well i'm glad that your
parents at least saw that i wish that
more parents
would because
the fact that uh that a young child has
difficulty sitting still in a public
school environment that's not an
indication there's anything wrong with
them
as i always say this is a that's if
there's something wrong here
if there's a disorder it's in the system
itself that ex expects kids to learn
that way because most kids cannot and
and especially boys cannot learn that
way if you just sit them down at a at a
desk for seven or eight hours a day
and give them busy work to complete
there's a there's a minority of kids and
most of them girls who can thrive in
that environment
but it's a very specific sort of
environment
that presents challenges to most people
i i couldn't even do it now at this age
um but kids especially especially boys
can
doesn't mean that they're disordered
means there's a problem with the system
itself
um
anna says why can't we flip the why do
you even care argument around i'm a
woman if a trans person called me a man
i wouldn't care
so why do they even care
yeah i mean that's that's an important
point it's the same thing for me like if
i i'm a man i'm aware that i'm a man i'm
quite confident in that i don't depend
on anybody else affirming me in my
manhood and so if somebody said that i
was a woman i would just
it
i
it would be embarrassing for them to say
that it wouldn't cause any kind of
crisis for me i wouldn't i wouldn't i
wouldn't have any identity crisis
because they said that
it wouldn't cause me to plunge into
despair
anything like that
because i know who i am and you anna
know who you are
well we find this is part of gender
ideology is that you're
you are
um your identity
is a very tenuous thing
and it requires that in order for it to
for it to kind of be held up
intact it requires that everyone around
you constantly affirm it and if one
person fails to affirm within the whole
thing shatters the pieces and that
should probably tell you something about
your perception of yourself which is
that it's probably not exactly accurate
um
let's see
meredith says or rather cool papa j
magic says just in case any of you
didn't know separation of church at
state was meant to prevent the state
from influencing the church not the
other way around uh that is that is
actually accurate that's how it was
originally used when thomas jefferson
used it um in his letter that he wrote
to the baptist
it was about it was the the concern that
if church and state intermingle it's not
that it's going to cause corruption of
the state but it will cause corruption
of the church
a little historical note that i think is
important and joyful catholicism says
matt i've been adding if you think matt
walls from the daily wire is hilarious
we'll probably get along just fine to
all of my online dating profiles it's
been a great conversation starter thanks
for all your help wish me luck in
finding a good catholic man
i do like that i think that's good
i think i think you know maybe go a
little bit farther requiring your date
to make an sbg loyalty pledge
is probably the way to go
and the good thing is it'll really
whittle down your candidates i mean
really whittle them down a lot
you'll probably scare away like 99 who
have no idea what you're talking about
but that makes selection a lot simpler
so that's the good thing
well there's no question that leftism
has been a disaster i am opposed to
leftism i don't know if you noticed that
yet but that's a little known fact about
me that's why we're discussing it all on
a very special episode of backstage
tonight not only will your favorite
daily wire host be there to break down
the current state of our country but
we'll also be welcoming a special guest
that's why you should tune in to catch
an all-new episode of us discussing
what's happening and how we're actively
fighting it on backstage tonight with
myself ben shapiro jeremy boring michael
knowles and andrew clavin it streams
tonight at seven o'clock eastern 6 pm
central on dailywire.com and our youtube
channel dailywire don't miss it and if
you're not a member yet time is running
out to head to dailywire.com subscribe
and use code build the future for 45 off
your membership this offer ends tomorrow
so don't miss out now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
cole and savannah labrandt are a husband
and wife duo parents of uh three kids
extremely successful youtubers their
channel the lebrant fam it's called has
over 13 million subscribers most of
their videos are dedicated to marriage
family life other crowd-pleasing kinds
of topics which have earned them a large
mainstream audience comprised of people
from all across the political spectrum
and so it took real courage then to
upload their latest video which is a 38
minute documentary titled simply
abortion
in the video they correctly dub abortion
the world's most deadly killer
and they compare abortion the abortion
death toll to all of the worst genocides
in history including the rwandan
genocide the
cambodian genocide the holocaust
the 60 million deaths from abortion far
outstripped the other three
combined
times three
they interview doctors pro-life
activists medical professionals and
others about the topic
they also say the money they raise from
the video which
should be a pretty substantial sum as it
already has two million views they're
going to give that money to a pregnancy
center so this is all again quite
courageous admirable and true
and if we know anything about our
culture it's that if you do something
courageous admirable and true then
you're guaranteed to be ripped to rip
the shreds for it which is indeed what
coal and savannah have experienced
media outlets like the daily mail have
fanned the outrage flames with headlines
like this
sickening youtube star couple is slammed
for comparing abortion to the holocaust
and branding it the world's most deadly
killer meanwhile leftist blogs like
jezebel have been even more direct
youtube couple shares disgusting video
comparing abortion to the holocaust the
lebrant fam who have more than 30
million subscribers posted anti-abortion
propaganda that left viewers enraged and
questioning why youtube allowed it
now youtube is allowing it to quote
unquote for now but their video has
apparently already been taken down by
instagram so instagram isn't allowing
as for the enraged viewers that is true
as well all you have to do is look up
savannah lebron's name on twitter and
you'll see the sort of
uh backlash they're dealing with so
reading now just the first few tweets
that pop up just to give you an idea
um
one of them says as someone who has had
an abortion savannah brandt can quite
literally go f herself how dare you as a
woman think it is your right to tell
others what to do with their own bodies
you grew up rich and married a rich man
who could help you raise your child you
are not
next someone else says f cole and
savannah lebron f them
and then i hope cole and savannah lebron
choke
and also cole and savannah lebron can
rot to be honest how dare you a
privileged white family with no
financial issues and no hardships in the
entire world compare abortions to the
holocaust an attempt at guilt-tripping
women who have had abortions and to push
your own
crappy religious agenda
now in fact i scrolled down a good way
and i didn't see even one single post
defending them
all of it is negative viciously negative
but that of course doesn't change the
fact that they're right abortion is a
holocaust in its own right and in terms
of sheer body count count it is the
worst holocaust in the history of the
world
that is the inevitable conclusion that
you must draw if you believe that
children in the womb are human beings
every pro-life person
must believe that abortion is the
deadliest holocaust in history
because that is the in absolutely
inescapable conclusion that follows
directly from the belief that the
victims of abortion are human beings
now of course i call it a belief but our
belief that humans in the womb are human
is similar to our belief
that gravity exists
and that like two plus two equals four
there's no leap of faith required in
this belief
it is belief not in an in some sort of
assumption but in a fact
the entity in the womb of a woman
is a being because he exists and he is
human because he was conceived by humans
thus he is a human being
and we know that he's alive because the
whole point of the abortion is to make
him not alive anymore
thus he is a living human being
abortion is the direct intentional
murder of a living human being
this kind of murder has been carried out
systematically and brutally
there's no non-brutal way to do it over
60 million times since roe v wade 60
million systemic murders is
a genocide it is a holocaust again this
is inescapable
no matter how it may make you feel to
hear it is inescapable
now in order to disprove or debunk the
holocaust claim you would need to rather
than cry and whine and do the whole how
dare you routine you would need to
demonstrate that the human in the womb
is not a human or else was not alive
before he was killed or else that
somehow killing an innocent and
defenseless human being doesn't count as
murder
you can't demonstrate or prove any of
that
nobody ever has
the pro-abortion side barely even
attempts because they know the attempt
will be futile so instead they just
flail about like demonically possessed
lunatics hoping that it passes for an
argument it doesn't
the lebrance are therefore vindicated
or at least
they would be
if they stuck to their guns
but this is where we get to the tragic
though not at all surprising end of the
story
vandala brant um seems to have deleted
all of her tweets but before she deleted
them according to the daily mail she
posted this quote we didn't mean it in a
hurtful way or anything i do understand
nothing should be compared to something
like the holocaust i didn't go through i
didn't go through to edit the video cole
edits most of our videos that are
uploaded i do apologize for any hurtful
things the video has done the uploading
of this video was to show how we plan to
help anyone going through something or
thinking of an abortion and to show our
view i totally do agree with you on it
being presented in another way as a mom
mom i'm still learning from things and i
do hope to learn from this on future
documentary documentaries that we do
damn it savannah
so not only does she apologize and
backtrack but she actually throws her
husband under the bus
it's the groveling trifecta
now
on one hand you may be far more generous
than me and you may be willing to cut
the lebran some slack
they were facing an onslaught of attacks
uh they're no doubt panicked that they
may have just alienated a significant
portion of their audience and they're
reacting out of fear
you may be willing to forgive the
groveling in that case you may be
willing to i am not
because nobody told the lebrands that
they had to make a video about abortion
they could have just kept posting sappy
heartwarming hallmark stuff and the kind
of stuff that's made them successful to
this point could have just done that but
if you're going to tread into these
waters then you you have a
responsibility
to stand firm by your convictions
i'm so tired of people
saying the right thing and then backing
down immediately it's like we're still
supposed to give them credit no i give
you zero credit
i give you zero credit on the assignment
all of the credit you would get for
speaking up immediately evaporates the
moment you apologize it's done
it's not just like you have zero it's
actually negative now because it's
better to say nothing it's much much
better
to say nothing than to say the right
thing only to apologize for it later
because when you apologize you are in
effect retracting the truth you spoke
and you're validating your insane rabid
foaming at the mouth critics
and you're emboldening those same rabid
dogs only further ensuring that they
treat the next person just as they
treated you
if you aren't prepared and willing to
stare down the mob and tell these hyenas
to screw off
then please just keep your mouth shut to
begin with
but as i said this isn't surprising uh
there were warning signs in the video
itself moments you know when you watched
the video where it seemed that maybe the
lebrons weren't fully invested in the
pro-life cause or maybe aware
of what the pro-life cause even is
moments like this
as we've been filming this documentary
we've been asked by our friends by
family by mentors why are we making this
so there's so much at risk why are we
even making this why are we adding flame
to an already
crazy burning fire and the answer is
just if one baby
is safe from this if one mom chooses to
keep her baby from it then it's all
worth it this documentary by no me just
trying to illegalize abortion after this
documentary you're still gonna have the
choice yeah you're still gonna have your
choice but i know that there's gonna be
one mom watching maybe five maybe ten
maybe a hundred maybe a thousand we have
no
idea the ripple effects but just for you
guys to know all the resources out there
and also for us as a church and just
just me and cole even just that how much
more we need to be doing well
obviously the
documentary itself isn't going to
illegalize abortion
but are you saying that you don't want
abortion to be illegal
that seems to be what they're saying
especially given savannah's response to
her critics on twitter we've already
gone over her apology but there was also
this
somebody tweeted at her saying
quote how disgusting of you guys to make
a video like that it's a choice my body
my effing choice the fact you tried
comparing the holocaust to abortions is
absolutely concerning that wasn't a
choice people were ripped from their
homes
now savannah should have responded to
that by reminding this person that in
abortion babies are also ripped from
their homes which are in the womb and
then ripped apart limb from limb
but instead she came back with a smiley
face and this statement she said we
clearly stated in the video it's still
your choice
huh so abortion is a holocaust it's the
murder of 60 million human babies and
yet it should still be a choice
and you don't want to make it illegal
you don't want the holocaust to be
illegal
at another point in the film they say
that they aren't pro-life or pro-choice
but pro-love
wait but why aren't you pro-life isn't
that the whole point of opposing
abortion
are you what taking a neutral stance on
the holocaust of infants
there's a certain lack of commitment in
the way that they framed things here and
that probably explains why they cracked
under the pressure and apologized and
deleted their entire social media
presence
they were ready to go halfway for the
pro-life cause which granted is is is
farther than a lot of people are willing
to go
but it's not good enough
halfway is not going to do it you got to
go the whole way
they thought a half measure would be
good enough it isn't
because this fight is real real you
either go all in
and you come ready for the war
or you stay home and stay out of it
so they thought they could just dip
their toes in the pool but not dive all
the way in they were wrong
and for that reason sadly at the end of
this it must be them today who are
canceled
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo vadosky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22. today on the ben shapiro show joe
biden tries to brush off inflation but
gets pooped on by a bird plus hollywood
won't say gay in china that's today on
the ben shapiro shall give it a listen